okay welcome to this video playing L
marmalade this is elma mcganum off
Grandmaster magram over fifty percent
score against him I think he's he always
was a Sicilian player okay maybe I get
this opportunity now to play the
poinciana yeah this is part of my
challenge playing the [ __ ] on e opening
which is really quite quiet rubbish but
ok should be seven is not exactly the
refutation okay you cannot refute the
opening probably but so mm just me just
e5 this is a lot like a lot like benoni
now but had played the pond siani you
cannot really say I didn't I'm free to
do whatever I want after I played it
even though this looks a lot like this
is it this is exactly an old Indian this
is the old Indian yet like as a
mechanism down I think um so I can wage
three them or not be for us also ok
let's go be fun
so what am I going to do we should be
three year maybe just toying a little
bit if you go snatch before i can drop
back but it's probably not doing that
nope I'll playing for a draw I'm just
trying to see what is up to neither of
six I don't play Bishop e3 again let's
see he sees far far too much of an
enterprising player to just just to do
nothing let's say five looks very I
don't know honestly speaking it just
looks bad but still has to be played and
refuted okay i can i can try to just
keep this thing with g form and I think
it's not a bad idea you cannot take the
five due to Bishop c4 pins and um Jim
what's your compensation here I mean the
point is also limiting black quite a bit
yeah that's probably the the relatively
best idea so 95 e6 would be great but
you can still take that on d5 it's not
it's not that convincing okay let's play
a little strengthening move and he does
the same if I play Bishop e3 he might
just take on c3 words okay but then I
cannot do that actually I cannot do that
okay this one but take now in 95 maybe
him and I takes g4s actually an idea
okay that is true so okay let's cover
that well that makes taking one c4 look
a little bit a little bit bad
okay let's check for only a good
practical tribe look at 5 40 page 5 yeah
okay okay so night h2 or up g one hook
g1 rook age 59 edge-to-edge form
probably this is heather's is not
protected the rook so okay let's start
with the move look here for Luke g2
Bishop g4 what it's really a shame me
that this nonsense is going to work
which is an awful awful play by black
just awful but it might work and
sometimes the problem move like f5 is
just a total rubbish but you still have
to refuel it in a blitz game and I'm in
a normal time controlled situation you
can have a good laugh about that but
it's not it's not so easy when you have
absolutely no time so poor mmm this
should be fun Queen g-form h2 just
protecting this and overlooking this
move yeah it's difficult it's really
difficult to keep this kind of thing
together
that's probably just lost somehow for
example um he can probably take c 2 and
play Queen f3 or something like that
yeah that's winning Queen have one made
is threatened no sorry rook h2o
threatened none I don't think I can
defend that
prom I don't know does he have other
things Bishop yeah Bishop's II to Queen
Eirias just good I can't go King g1 in
this line maybe I'm not made immediately
that it's possible
okay if it's not taking 1 C 2 okay he
takes Queen f3 threatens rook h2 I mean
I have to play king g one maybe I'm
surviving this at least for the moment
quite miraculously that's all only moves
hmm takes just take it what is the point
then rook age 2 nite X is made okay so
maybe I get the quick check check this
is time warning petrol I guess orissa
system made Jeff check check check check
check game Jim yeah wyd really should
win out to f5 it's a bit of a shame
early it's just just just a winner with
a decent time control let's say yeah but
okay it's blitz chess and you can play
all kinds of rubbish so the real issue
was that here here I really Nyjah 495 is
in fact very good I saw this idea but
not at this particular moment this is
the idea yeah an IG form this is hitting
the thing is I really I wanted to do
this it's still not working yeah so 95
was one way to refute it and this was
even better keeping c4 under control
after that he basically has no move yeah
he has to play I don't know h5 or some
kind of thing that steers up trouble but
objectively speaking them white is close
too close to wind down f5 is just it's
just I'm just a player but ok I allowed
all this
and here night h h4 went here this this
only move and hear ya Bishop g4 is the
engine recommendation yeah I have to
have to give give up material none this
is ruben two pieces for the queen but my
position is uncoordinated very
uncoordinated like this and he enters
mm-hm not sure about this but i think in
a practical game i'm probably just
losing him because of the bad piece
coordination I mean a practical blitz
game of course and here Bishop f5 wins
yeah so where I was the win Bishop g4
here was winning because here ya hear
there's Queen f5 while those kind of
things are tricky okay so this is this
and after that I'm okay Queen f5s the
engine move yeah just playing the
position not trying to win immediately
and here okay I quit so I could have
taken that I wasn't sure he really
irritated me with this but check here
I'm I'm winning I'm winning him okay now
I couldn't I couldn't really figure that
out he was down to 13 seconds and I had
one minute yeah maybe I really should
have taken a moment there I was glad to
have that I get to queens traded I
should have thought about this really
check because here after Queen area
still smell much better check check
check check check check sure okay well i
don't know maybe this is an okay result
considering that yeah I was winning out
of the opening and but then totally
screwed it up so maybe that's even
get out to a draw okay well thanks for
watching